thank you
everybody my name is Kevin I work for a
outfit called twilio and if you haven't
had a chance to use twilio before it
lets you do cool stuff like make and
receive phone calls send and receive
text or picture messages and I enable
what calling in your desktop browsers or
mobile apps and also I actually wrote
the node module for twilio um and I
think I'm actually going to add a high
level helper that is a one-liner so that
Angelina Fabro brings you uh brings you
tacos as you saw in the last one of the
last talks uh so that was that was
pretty awesome uh great use of twilio
and if you uh think any of that stuff
might be fun to play around with uh just
go ahead and npm install twilio
um but that's not what I'm here to talk
about today
um I'd like to talk a little bit about
again one of my favorite tools for use
with node.js which is browserify
um for me it's actually sort of the key
tool which unlocks the promise of node
to allow you to share code between the
client and the server side and it's also
really useful even uh beyond the browser
rule of browserify allows you to do is
to package up the node.js module system
and basically create a single Javascript
file that you can evaluate in any
JavaScript environment that lets you
write your JavaScript in such a way
where you can you know structure your
code in as node.js style common JS
modules so it's really cool if you
haven't used it before I definitely
encourage you to do so because it allows
you to start to share a culture if you
will with both the client and the server
side in your JavaScript code
just having the same language on both
ends of the wire is pretty cool but if
you actually want to reuse code it
should be written in the same style file
and kind of live in the same ecosystem
as you know as one another so that's why
I think browserify really enables a lot
of the really cool stuff that we sort of
are hoping to realize with node.js so uh
if you are writing a node.js module uh
today that you're supporting um out on
npm a lot of modules with browserify
today uh will just work so it could be
that you have no work to do uh to make
your module browser refiable
um but you might want to do a little bit
of extra work if your module meets one
of these two criteria so if you're if
the functionality that you're shipping
in your module has sort of complementary
apis that you can uh that are slightly
different that you can use both on the
client and the server side one example
would be the Ws module the websocket
popular websocket library for node in
the browser when you require it it gives
you a cross-platform or a you know a
browser-specific version of the
websocket implementation that exists on
that browser and and then on the server
side it gives you a websocket server
that you can then use so if your module
sort of could benefit from having sort
of um nice nice interfaces that are uh
that are connected on both the client
and the server then you probably want to
look at some of the more advanced
features of browserify also sometimes
your module isn't just going to work so
if your module does any kind of a file
system i o or something along those
lines obviously that's not going to work
in node or excuse me with browserify but
browser5 does provide shims for most of
node's core libraries so a lot of the
npm universe just kind of works today so
your module might be one of them if not
I would definitely recommend taking a
look at how you can make it a browser
file compatible if that if that makes
sense because a lot of folks are sort of
moving to browserify as an alternative
to some of the asynchronous module
loaders that purely sort of live in the
browser to again to to realize that
promise of having the same style of code
exist both in node and client-side code
so the there's basically if you want to
design a module to work with browser fi
there's about three things you need to
look at so the first thing is uh sort of
looking at the entry point for your
module and saying like you know if if
there is sort of a different interface
that you want to expose on the client
versus the server uh you can actually
specify in your package.j on a different
uh entry point where your module begins
so we'll take a look at how you uh do
that you'll also Define any shims that
you need to insert so if the HTTP
implementation that ships with
browserify doesn't meet your needs
there's a way that you can create your
own custom browsers browser shim for a
node module that you use in your
application and we'll take a look at how
to do that we also have a source
Transformations that are available in
browserify so if your module is written
in coffeescript and you need a
coffeescript compiled before your module
is rated for use in browser if I you can
specify that package.json as well so at
this point I wanted to actually write
some code to show you how that would
work so
um basically here I have two files a
browser.js and a server.js and I'm going
to create a node module that's going to
work in both of those environments the
server being just a plain vanilla node
program and then the browser.js being a
file that I'm going to package up with
browserify to ship and include as a
script tag I ain't a script tag
potentially in a web browser so let's
create a new directory I'll call that
demo module
and we'll go in there and do an npm in
it
and we'll just accept a lot of these
default values
okay so now we have a package.json for
our program
and by default when you create a new npm
package there's this main main attribute
here which which sort of specifies the
entry point for your module so uh if so
when browserify packages up your module
by default it's going to look at this
main attribute first and that's going to
it's going to use that as the entry
point for your module because it
observes the same module loading
algorithms that that node npm use so if
you don't have a different interface
from browser to server then that's fine
and you can leave that just as it is so
let's create
index.js
and we'll open that up in a text editor
here
not that one we're looking for this one
okay great so uh here's our demo module
directory and inside here uh we'll just
create
something like say hi
and say console.log
server or something along those lines
okay so here's my version of the module
that works in node and now if I want to
have a browser-specific version of my
module I'll create another file I'll
call it uh
client.js
and in this one
I'm going to have a the same interface
say hi
give that a function and alert
hello something along those lines okay
so on the in the browser I want to use
this as the entry point for my module so
the way that I specify that in
package.json is by providing a another
attribute called browser so when
browserify processes your module it's
going to look for this attribute in your
package.json if you set it to a string
it's basically going to be a relative
path to a file in your directory uh that
is you want to use as the entry point so
I can just specify
client excuse me dot slash client.js
so uh now I have a module that I can use
in this code here if I go up directory
server.js well I don't actually have to
go through and type all that I think you
guys are kind of with me there so
basically here are my two entry points
for uh client and server now the other
thing that you might have to do besides
sort of specifying a new uh entry point
there is is provide some kind of or
provide some other shims for other
functionality or other files that you
want to override when you're writing a
module that's going to run in the
browser so the way that we do that in
package.json is rather than setting this
browser property to a string I can
actually set this to be an object
so I still want to have a different
entry point for my browserified package
but in this case I'm not going to sort
of override Maine over in the keys
section of this of this Json object I'm
going to specify the file that I want to
override so I'm going to say uh
dot slash
index.js this is the file that would be
loaded if my module is going to be used
on the server but instead I want to load
up dot slash
client.js so now I've you know that was
basically the same as just setting this
string equal to the browser property
before so now I have my different entry
point and then let's say I have a custom
shim for the HTTP library and core node
if I want to specify something like that
I would just go dot slash
you know my http.js and then I would be
able to implement my own browser shim
for the HTTP Library as well so those
are kind of the two main things that
you'll have to do to prepare your module
for browserify specify you know an
alternate entry point and any shims that
you need another thing that you might
have to do is specify some Source
Transformations if you're it'll
basically allow you to process code in a
stream and output a modified version of
that code that I'll run in the browser
and there's a lot of existing
Transformers out there for browserify
one of the more popular one uh more
popular ones is coffeeifi which will
basically process your copy script code
convert it to JavaScript and then
include it in your browserify module so
the way that we specify that
is with the browser fi field of
package.json
and inside this inside this object we
have a property transforms
and that's going to be an array of
strings which will point to modules
inside your project so let's if I had
some coffee script that I wanted to
process before my module or as my module
gets browserified I just specify that I
want to run it through this
transformation and if you do have a
transformation like this one you'd also
have to add it in your modules
dependencies
it will have to be resolvable by browser
if I as a dependency so you just add a
dependency there for coffeeify so to
prepare your module you're going to
again just do those three things specify
new entry point shim any uh any core
node libraries or modules within your
own application that won't work in the
browser
unmodified and then you can also specify
Transformations for your code so those
are probably the things that you will
need to look at doing to make your
module sort of compatible with browser
fi
now uh
the reason why I think this is kind of
interesting is sort of uh specific to
twilio and what we do with our module so
um with uh tutorial SDK there's a server
side component that has a rest API which
we uh provide sort of a high level
object wrapper for in the npm module but
we also have this client-side SDK which
lets you make a Voiceover IP phone calls
which Marcy used such a great effect in
her uh in her presentation earlier so we
have a situation where we have an API
that all sort of hangs together and has
client and server side components so I
actually kind of looked at an API that
similar to like what socket i o provides
where it has sort of a elegant way of
including both client and server side
functionality at least initially it was
in a single package now it's in two
different ones but this seemed to be a
really good use case for twilio's voice
over IP so what we have to do today is
you know your browser code has to talk
to your web application to generate a
capability token which basically
empowers the browser to make phone calls
and then your node application has to
respond to an Ajax request and then your
browser talks to twilio to initiate the
Voiceover IP call twilio talks to your
application to get uh you know
instructions for how to handle the call
before ultimately you can actually place
that voice over IP phone call between
your customer and the person that you
would like to your browser and the
person that you would like to talk to so
this seemed to be a really great
opportunity to design a module using
using browserifi that will provide two
different interfaces on both the client
and the server so I'd like to show you a
little bit of of how I would Envision
this working in an application so
um
let's go ahead and open up a simple demo
so uh here we have a node application
um pay no attention to this basically
this is uh just a module that I created
that creates sort of a pre-configured
Express for web application so this is
an Express web app that is set up with
some useful middleware for you know
automatically browserifying certain
files and applying less and stuff like
that so but it's basically an Express
for web app and then we require a
special version of the twilio module and
then I can actually use the twilio
module to basically Mount some server
side capabilities that will handle some
of that token generation and that other
song and dance that we saw before so
this is the uh the API that I want to
expose on the server side and then on
the client side I wanted to sort of
drastically simplify the code that would
be necessary to actually create a voice
over IP call between two parties so here
we just include from a twilio CDN a
JavaScript file which has sort of the
core basic JS SDK and then here we have
a browser found file that we're loading
up from our web application and in that
file
um we have jQuery that we've installed
uh via npm so we can you know use that
like an npm module and also the twilio
module again using a customized version
of it on my local file system and then
we just have a couple of handlers here
that will you know initialize the
outbound phone call with you know
twilio.dial it'll hang up when the user
wants me to and then initially because
this JavaScript is being generated on
the server I'm able to just call twilio
connect and I already and I don't
necessarily have to make Ajax calls or
do any any stuff to you know fetch a
capability token or set up my server
side because my JavaScript was generated
on my server I know where it lives and I
can sort of automate that entire process
so what I'm going to do is fire this up
actually it looks like it's already
running and I do in order to do voice
over IP I need for this web application
to be on the public internet does
anybody here or use a tool called ngrok
ngrok it's a port forwarder couple
people okay so if you don't use engrock
uh and take nothing else away from this
talk it's an amazing tool it will change
your life definitely go install it
basically assigns a public-facing URL to
a a local port on your laptop so if you
have a local node server a railed server
or something like that you want to
quickly put it on the internet so that
your friends or clients can check it out
ngrok is a great tool to let you do that
so basically what I have running is a
simple application that will by default
initiate a conference call between
somebody in their browser so would you
mind being my guinea pig in the front
row I'm going to come pick on you would
you mind going to kw.nrock.com
sorry to pick on you like that but I
would I need at least one one person KW
Dot ngrok.com
and just click on that button to say uh
join a conference call and twilio's uh
Julio's clientside SDK will use the
webrtc apis built into the Chrome
browser to initiate a phone call
and we'll dial in
waiting for that second party
foreign
magic of webrtc yeah I know our voices
are connecting through the inner tube so
um so yeah uh basically the the reason I
wanted to show that is um it's it's one
example where you have a module and you
know that you're going to have server
set apis and client-side apis that are
going to have to interact with one
another and uh if you and you can
present sort of a unified interface to
both the client and the server if you
write your write your module in this way
and in the uh in this particular example
of the twilio module I was able to share
code between the client-side SDK that is
being used in the browser and the server
side SDK that I use that you would use
to you know contact the rest API or to
generate capability tokens on the server
so uh I definitely recommend that you
check out uh browserify it's a great uh
if you're using node uh it makes a ton
of sense because uh you're basically
going to be using the same one package
manager uh one style of structuring your
code and you'll be able to realize a lot
more of the benefits of having
JavaScript on both a client and the
server so uh some of the documentation
for the browserify specific stuff you
see is up here don't worry about copying
it down this is actually all on my
SlideShare account which is
slideshare.net K Winery if you have any
questions feel free to come track me
down but again yeah I think browser5 is
a really cool tool and uh definitely
worth checking out if you're using that
so thank you very much
thank you
foreign